you
[Music]
all right thank you very much for coming
today we were really lucky to have a
Kenneth Redinger come here to talk about
quantum sorry a quantum computing
verification and validation kenny is
actually one of the the expert in the
field he's done a lot of extensions on
on gate set tomography and also
developed an excellent library for doing
this as well as randomized benchmarking
and other tasks that are required for
this some of the work that he's done to
that that I think is particularly
impressive is he's done work showing
that in ion traps they're capable of
performing gates below the thresholds
with the surface code for the first time
in a rigorous fashion and so I'm really
excited and looking forward to hearing
what Kenny has to say about where the
fields going in the future thank you
thank you very much anything really very
very happy to be here or really excited
to talk with you about some of work that
I've done thank you all for for coming
to to listen and please don't hesitate
to interrupt with questions or comments
emergency to hear with what people have
to say as well so just to get started so
I want to talk about QC V V and this is
an acronym stands for Kwan
characterization verification and
validation and I'm going to send the
first portion of the talk discussing a
what do we mean by QC VV what what good
is it for why should we care about it
what are things that we would like to be
able to do with it how can it help us
achieve full-scale universal quantum
computation then want to talk a bit
about how we've used QC v V techniques
si India how we develop certain QC v V
tools there and how we've used it to
dramatically improve experimental qubit
implementations at Sandia and then I
just want to wrap up by discussing some
future directions for QC vvv some some
protocols that we've been developing at
Sandia more recently as well as some
thoughts about where we think qvvv is
going to be going over the next few
years so I want to start with a story
from the future
imagine that it is May 11th 2029 and
just in time for Richard Fineman one
hundred and 11th birthday you are all
set to turn on the world's first
full-scale universal quantum computer
and it will look you know something like
this of course and so you you turn it on
and you want to give it a simple
question to start with you say computer
factor 42 this would be pretty easy
right so get even you divide by 2 you
get 21 you run Shore should be fun the
quantum computer thinks for a bit and
the quantum computer says with infinite
majesty 42 is six-nine wait a second
this doesn't seem right I say a quantum
computer are you sure clunker says yes
yes I'm sure it's it's 6 and 9 and so
you you rerun the algorithm you run it
several times to check and you see
indeed every single time you get the
same wrong answer
hmm this this is not quite what you
would hope for you check you say ok
maybe maybe there was a bug in the
software maybe maybe we didn't implement
sure properly so you go and you check
the logical coat the the software the
logical level and you see indeed no bugs
it's exactly what it's supposed to be
say ok maybe maybe we did our error
correction well maybe there's something
wrong with the instructions at the
physical level
you check the software for the physical
level for the error correction and that
also all checks out so now you're sort
of stuck you have a quantum computer but
it doesn't work and you don't know why
oh the problem is at this point sure you
find yourself in this situation you have
a device that's sufficiently complicated
that you don't really know what to do to
debug it and so in some times the whole
point of qvvv is to prevent us from
being in situations like this and so so
how do we hope to to prevent things like
this from happening so well what do we
mean when we talk about qcv right so
this acronym for character
Asian verification and validation let's
unpack this a little bit so first with
notion of characterization we want to
answer questions like what are my qubits
doing what are the gates on my quantum
systems doing so we answered these with
with quantities like process matrices we
have verification this is we want it we
want to verify our mycube is good enough
to do things that i want to do like
quantum error correction so you can
measure these things perhaps with things
like fidelity for your process matrices
and then we have validation and it
sounds similar to verification it's a
little bit different it's essentially
asking the question are we asking the
right questions with with our
verification questions what are the
metrics that actually matter what are
the things that we really care about to
be able to do the things that we want to
be able to do so do we care about
diamond norms or Fidelity's do we
actually care about thresholds are there
other things that we want to be
measuring instead so so this is this is
the basic idea the point in some sense
is that when you have qubits they're
going to be errors that you see with
with the operations with with the qubits
themselves and you want to know what
went wrong why did these why did these
operations not do what I wanted them to
do even if there are errors though is
that okay can i still make do with the
noisy gates or do i have to fix them if
i have to fix them how do i fix them so
in some sense these are the questions
that we're trying to answer with QC v V
techniques so you know what is that we
really want to do with quantum computers
well we want to run circuits right so
this is of course for a gate based model
of quantum computation there are other
other sorts of models as well but we're
going to be talking today in particular
about running circuits although these
comments more or less without loss of
generality apply to to other paradigms
as well so you want to run circuits and
things that look more or less like this
there are some problems of course or
some some some stumbling block that one
has to has to overcome first quantum
information is fragile
right we know that quantum systems
decohere very easily it's very easy to
lose quantum information just because
you know your qubit interacts with the
bath a straight photon hits that you
name it you look at it funny you lose
your quantum information okay
you also want to be able to do
operations on your quantum system you
want to be able to do a coherent
operation of course these operations
themselves are noisy and in some sense
this is reasonably easy to see why this
is right so suppose you have for example
an ion qubit and what are things that
can mess up ion qubit light how do you
manipulate ion cupid light so you you
want to make sure that we know you're
using your lasers on your ion qubits
that you're using just the right light
and not the wrong light and of course we
know that that you can't have infinitely
narrow bandwidth on your lasers so this
going is going to be some fundamental
noise that you're going to encounter
with with these sorts of operations okay
so what do we want to do we want to be
able to perform quantum computation
perform coherent operations but still
protect the underlying quantum states
that store the quantum information and
so in order to do this we're probably
going to use something like quantum
error correction there are of course
some proposals that avoid using quantum
error correction but you know we're
pretty sure that we're going to use
quantum error correction if you're able
to avoid using quantum error correction
that's great but either way you're going
to have to have extraordinarily low
areas especially if you think you can
actually avoid using quantum error
correction and either way you're going
to have to have some notion of fault
tolerance you want to be able to achieve
to actually be able to do error
correction and then full scale quantum
computation so so I've talked sort of in
broad generalities about how quantum
information is fragile and how things
can go wrong but more specifically what
are the things that could possibly go
wrong with your quantum computer so
there are I think more or less broadly
speaking three kinds of errors that you
can encounter
you can encounter coherent errors
unitary err
you want to do a tea gate but instead
you do the rotation with an extra PI
over 16 rotation or maybe you don't do
an X rotation it's an X plus epsilon Z
rotation so these are errors that are
relatively easy to diagnose and
relatively easy to fix going up in terms
of things that can be a little bit a
little bit harder to correct we have
stochastic errors right just because we
know that there's going to be
interaction with a bath you're always
going to have things like amplitude
damping or t1 processes your thermal
relaxation you'll have things like be
phasing t2 processes these are things
that you can engineer your quantum
systems to to have 1 t1 x 1 t 2 x so you
have minimize this stochastic error but
these are still going to be some
fundamental issues that you're going to
to encounter with your system and then
there's everything else what I call non
Markovian noise although I will note
that this is sort of an overloaded term
so I want to be clear what I mean by
this I mean specifically things that you
cannot represent as completely positive
traits preserving maps on your quantum
system of the fixed dimension that you
want them to be that are static in time
like I said everything else so what are
what are sorts of things like that that
you might find my time that there's
time-dependent maybe there's a drifting
electric field or a magnetic field that
drifts in your lab so your your gate now
is not the same as the gate that you
have in five minutes or maybe you let a
theorist like me into the lab and I
bumped the table and all of a sudden you
see a big shift in your qubit frequency
okay
there can be context-dependent this can
be a variety of different things but one
way to think about a certain example of
context dependences say a gate that I
perform after a different gate is
different than if I didn't perform the
previous gate so I see not now is
different than a C not if I perform the
t gate before the Phenom for example you
can have linkage you can that assay you
can
go outside your two-level system you can
go to some higher lying state or some
state adjacent to to the qubit subspace
this is something that in particular we
know can happen and things like
superconducting architectures where the
two qubit interactions are frequently
mediated by going through a higher lying
state and then you depopulate that state
to go back to the qubit subspace if you
don't completely to populate the third
state then you have leakage there can be
crosstalk if I have a cubed over here
that I'm idling and a cubed over here
that I'm driving with with X gates it's
possible I accidentally drive some X
rotations over here or maybe I somehow
entangled it too and of course plenty
more so there are all sorts of things
that can go wrong with your with your
qubits and of course further
complicating the matter the number of
parameters that you want to write down
to describe your system grows
exponentially with qubit number and
that's true even just for these first
two types of errors right it gets even
worse if you want to include all sorts
of non Markovian dynamics so so we want
to be able to somehow somehow
characterize these these kinds of errors
so we can fix them so we can have have
fault-tolerant quantum computation and
of course the other thing to point out
is that when we consider all these non
Markovian kinds of errors these are
things that threshold theorems
essentially say nothing about right
we're typically assuming that oh the
kinds of errors we have are uncorrelated
in space are uncorrelated in time
they're restricted still to the qubit
subspace so now listen you start
throwing these kinds of errors in and it
gets it gets much worse it becomes much
more problematic so broadly speaking
what do I think that choose evv should
offer I think there are more or less two
different kinds of things that we should
want from from cuny techniques first is
a framework for describing and
quantifying errors of we want to be able
to somehow quantitatively describe
quantum
so typically we think about things like
process matrices which are very useful
for describing quantum processes
provided of course they don't have to
capture non Markovian dynamics given a
particular mathematical description you
want to come up with reasonable metrics
to compute so you can say this date is
better than that date so do this gate or
make this gate even better so we can
actually achieve something like a fault
tolerance threshold and it's important
for this framework I think to be
architecture agnostic that is to say you
want to be able to have tools that can
describe in a unified language
superconducting qubits and ion qubits
and semiconductor qubits you name it for
a couple of reasons first you want to
make cross-platform comparisons and this
isn't so that you can say oh well my
qubits better than your qubit it's so
that you can have an understanding as to
whether or not the particular
architecture you're pursuing if it even
makes any sense right you say that that
the kinds of error rates that we can
achieve with this qubit technology if
you know that that you can't ever
possibly hope to get the same kind of
error rate for some other technology
then you know maybe you want to rethink
the architectures that you're exploring
you also want to be able to learn from
and inform other architectures right so
obviously yes the physical operations
that you perform on the different
systems are going to be different but
there's still a lot to be learned from
the different systems that that are
applicable across the architecture so
for example if you want to reduce the
impact of quasi static noise we've
learned that things like
dynamically correcting gates are very
useful and it turns out that that's
going to be true across different
architectures even if the details of
those the DCG sequences that you run may
or may not be different but the point is
you know you run some particular
protocol you see how it improves your
metric say ah I bet that this will work
in another platform as well and you can
try that and and and learn more about
the system and learn more about quantum
formation processors and
by being able to do these sorts of them
so in some sense this is this is the
descriptive task that qvvv
I think can offer and there's a
prescriptive one as well that is to say
the protocols for diagnosing and
correcting error they say not just this
is what your qubits are doing but here's
a way that you can figure out what your
qubits are doing here's a way that you
can figure out how to make your qubits
better and so there are a whole bunch of
different protocols just to name a few
so randomized benchmarking is one there
are a whole bunch of different flavors
of phase estimation there's data
tomography Bolden gates that tomography
because that's what I'm going to spend a
reasonable portion of the talk
discussing this is of course a non
exhaustive list there are plenty of
other things that you can do as well so
before we start talking about gates of
tomography I want to talk a little bit
about mathematical description of
quantum processes so the so I said that
um you know if we really want a full
description we want to be able to
somehow capture non Markovian dynamics
we don't have full descriptions yes
we're just going to go with the
Markovian picture for now and to do this
we use what's called wee-wee oval
representation also called Hilbert
Schmidt space the the the basic idea is
that you can take a density matrix in
the basis of poly matrices so something
to know just a single qubit density
matrix looks something like this and
we're going to vectorize it in a
particular fashion we're going to
represent it like this and similarly we
can take effects from measurements and
look like this and what's nice about
this picture then is any Markovian
process that can act on the state you
can write down as a matrix that looks
like this and then if you want to
compose quantum processes you just
multiply the process matrices or
sometimes referred to as the super
operators you multiply them together and
they've some nice structure to so we'll
note that the first row is just one
followed by all zeros indicating that
your map is traced preserving you have
this 3 by 3 sub block
lambdas this is the unitl sub-block so
this captures all unitary dynamics as
well as any sort of decoherence
phenomenon that is not amplitude down if
you've got some amplitude dampening
phenomenon then that gets captured by by
these tabs this column vector over here
and then if I want to know given a
particular input state given a quantum
circuit specified by some some gates and
then a outcome effect I want to what's
the probability of seeing this outcome
you just get it through matrix
multiplication you just get essentially
the weighted inner product so then if I
want to actually go and run some sort of
QC V V protocol in general they're going
to be specified as quantum circuits the
edges you specify a collection of
quantum circuits which specify state
preparation some series of gate
operations and a measurement you then
get from this collection you repeat each
of these sequences some number of times
you get frequencies which approximate
the underlying probabilities for the
different effects for the different
circuits that you've run and you you
crunch some numbers using your favorite
algorithm and you come up with an
estimate of the gate set or maybe an
estimate of some parameters that
describe the gate that's maybe something
like the randomized benchmarking number
okay but so the basic idea is I have
sort of a nice black box picture here I
push the state preparation button I push
some some gate buttons I push the
measurement button and then I get a a
light a green light or a red light
corresponding to the different possible
outcome okay and you just do this a
bunch of times to build up statistics so
why we know why would one do this why do
we want to have actual characterization
of the of the gates of the super
operators well so if we want to have
quantum error correction we want to be
able to satisfy some fault tolerance
threshold right and so if we want to
consider general errors the threshold is
specified in terms of a diamond jinora
and we want to be below six point seven
times ten to the minus four
what is the diamond norm this is
essentially a measure of a worst case
error rate basically we're maximizing
over all possible inputs including input
on multiple qubits more than just what
my date is acting on and then we look at
the the one norm so essentially we're
looking at over all possible different
measurements that we can perform and we
want to say what's the worst possible
performance that this gate could have
over all possible inputs and all
possible measurements and of course it
sort of makes sense that we want to
think about a worst-case metric because
we want to consider the most possible
general errors of course I say general I
still mean things that are static and
time things that are are Markovian okay
you might ask well can I can't I just
instead of using the diamond or
something that sort of can capture a
little bit more simple things easier to
measure like infidelity or the RB number
what you could if you want to but the
problem is the bounds are kind of loose
I be diamond norm in particular bounds
the infidelity from below below this
assuming from below that would be the
square root of the infidelity so if you
want to confirm that you have a diamond
norm error on the order of ten to the
minus four you would need to demonstrate
an infidelity on the order of ten to the
minus eight and that requires a lot of
experimental resources the best diamond
means the best R be in fidelities that
we've seen in any experimental systems
are on the order of like 10 to the minus
six and those are like real kuro
experiment is the question those is you
know that's a good question um so sorry
I did you mean the the relation between
diamond norm and infidelity
yeah uh sophisticated instability is
this video though um that's probably not
super pessimistic although that's
something that we're still we're still
thinking about this rate is really
awesome to dimension
there's very there's a dimensional
factory out so what the West pays on
both the exaggerations we've done a
bunch from the damage so so I mean um as
I said I'm not I'm not sure I'm not sure
I fully I fully understand Oh
so I mentioned you know this is a
tailless Pompeii but they major the
realism originally planned and saturated
right so there's a clinic or do some
example but oh sure ei right both by
some constant factors as a function of
dimensional selecting you know do
remember by any chance with the constant
factor looks like oh so so it's um I
believe that it's proportional to the
dimension I don't know if the top of my
head I believe that sorry but and
certainly where you can saturate the
bound if you have pure stochastic error
or if you like take two polarizing noise
right is is one user to get independent
as close as possible then you get them
as maximally for our part when you have
I just pure unitary air they're another
freshman well it was more just a common
pure well David Renee had been working a
lot on what types of norm are good for
characterizing logical failure rates
when you when you perform a friction and
from provide understanding sometimes a
diamond norm could be way off by several
orders of magnitude if you if you want
to use it to you know correct write the
particular logic okay and it really also
depend a lot on a noise model bit so
we're okay so make sure I enjoyed you're
saying prepare properly so if we're
talking about logical error rates um
that that wasn't terribly surprised me
because we're just talking about the
physical error rate or the physical
qubits as opposed to the error rate on
the logic you right so that's sort of a
different a different kind of quantity
that we're measuring that right but but
you're like you're using the iron or to
a lower bound on with the threshold
should be right so so so okay so so the
if if the observation is that when you
have logical qubits and you want to
measure the logical error rates that
diamond norm is not appropriate that
that's enough I don't find a turbine
surprising right
the question here this is a little bit
different this is saying what do the
error rates beyond the physical qubits
to form up logical qubits that we can
correct you with error correction come
on another coming along this line it's
not that the bound is loose it's just
that we we care about my mother because
that especially happens given by the
diamond compound was sure sure but but
but if it were the case that we could
say that that the bound between diamond
orman infidelity was was linear where as
opposed to quadratic then we could go
ahead and you know maybe just do our B
and I have to worry about doing full
gate characterization right the design I
come all I'm saying is that the number
10 is 8 these find no means pessimistic
for chopping number just a convention oh
sure sure no of course but then but then
the point is if you want to
experimentally get this kind of number
then directly through you know without
doing full tomography doing something
like RB then all of a sudden this
becomes very very difficult that's a
that's a calculation method dependency
I'm not sure I understand yeah all I'm
saying is that naive number or the
metrics should be kind of the purpose
you should use short that one there's no
best measure
oh sure Aaron all right right right I'm
not saying this is that this is the best
measure right the the point is that you
say to given given this threshold given
that it's given in terms of a diamond or
if you instead said I want to I want to
get this with our B right I want to
verify that my system is below this
threshold using our V then you would
have to get an RV number that was about
ten to the minus eight and that is at
this point experimentally inaccessible
it's something like the best that we've
seen right now are about ten to the
minus six is that never accessible by
the something that just is you know
still a ways away so a ways off does
that make sense
remember related you take this offline
and just go success more later so right
so Sciences so so the point is if you
want to actually in sometimes how do you
want to how would one go about
demonstrating that you've satisfied this
bound so you could do something like RB
but there are some problems as we've
just discussed you could instead do
tomography on the gates right if you
have actual tomographic reconstruction
of the gate then you can go and actually
explicitly compute what the diamond norm
is so if we want to do tomography of
some sort what are the things that we
want we wanted to be calibration free on
explain what I mean more precisely by
that in a moment but basically what I
mean is we need to not have a set of pre
calibrated input States and measurements
that standard tomography protocol is
typically assumed well are to be
actually complete right it has to be
comma graphically complete there are
certain sorts of partial talk
tomographic protocol that people have
proposed that can be very useful of and
are cheaper than full tomography uh but
if it's not complete you can't actually
go and compute the diamond one we want
it to be efficient and I don't mean
efficient in sort of the computer
science theory
sense in terms of being polynomial but
just in terms of being experimentally
reasonable something that we could
expect experimentalists to actually be
able to do ah and we also wanted to be
Markovian certifying if I have a
tomographic protocol and it tells me
that my gates are very nice and says
here here are here's the best fit to the
data given our map are you given given
the map between the data and the gate
set and it says that we're below the
fault tolerance threshold that's great
but how do I know that these that my
protocol in some sense isn't just lying
to me right we want to make sure that
the data that we have are fit by the
estimate that we come up with and so so
we're going to see over the next several
slide how we can come up with a
tomographic protocol that can satisfy
all of these criteria so first I want to
talk a little bit about a standard
tomography right so standard state and
process tomography so if you wanted to
do standard state smog rafi you do
something like this say okay I know
state I want to characterize you prepare
the state and then you do say as the
measurement you do this a bunch of times
you build up good statistics and say
okay I want to do a Y measurement well
you don't have a native Y measurement
typically in physical systems so what
you do is you simulate it you prepare
your state you apply some pre calibrated
gate
you do a measurement they look good
statistically you do the same thing then
for X so you know I've got x y&z
measurements on your state you can then
reconstruct the state the problem of
course is that if you want to do this
you need to have pre calibrated
measurements you need to have pre
calibrated gate so how do you calibrate
your gate well you would do process
tomography and on this process
tomography work well you start with some
pre calibrated States and then you
sandwich your unknown state or assume
the unknown map between your pre
calibrated state and pre calibrated
measurements and you want to simulate
various different input States to use
more pre calibrated gates and you want
to simulate various measurements so you
put in more pre calibrated gates and so
as you see it's sort of circular it
comes processed tomography all the way
down and so you can't you know really
actually do this in practice in a way
that is calibration free so what we want
we want some sort of calibration free
tomography so to do this we use
something that we call gig vet
tomography and this was an idea that was
first introduced several years ago at
IBM and something that we spent a lot of
time working on to develop X and Bo and
so so the idea is what we wanted to want
to simultaneously characterize all of
our gates and all of our input States
and all of our measurements in a way
that then solves the self the the
self-consistency problem is calibration
problem and just a notational aside so
we're going to now start referring to
the state preparations as with this we
call a super cat it's got an extra angle
brackets indicates that this is a vector
that lives in Hilbert Schmidt space
instead of Hilbert space and then the
dual to that is a super bra and so then
the point is that the probability for
witnessing a certain outcome given a
quantum circuit is just given by this
weighted inner product so so a process
tomography looks something like this
right we have a variety of known
information we complete input States and
a variety of information and complete
unknown measurements instead we're going
to do is something that looks very
similar to it but not quite the same so
we call this linear gate set tomography
linear inversion gate that tomography
and the idea is that you form up a
collection of information only complete
input States by choosing what we call
fiducial gate sequences F from your set
of gate operations that you can perform
you don't actually know what these are
because you haven't tomograph them yet
but if you pick a sufficiently large set
of eight operations to perform to it to
form your fiducials out of you can be
reasonably sure that they're going to be
informational e complete that is say
you're probing enough of the Bloch
sphere and then we do the same thing for
for the measurements okay
Ansel writes the purpose of fiducials is
wanna make sure that the inputs
dates and the measurements are
informational incomplete without having
done calibration we're not going to
perform two classes of experiments the
first look just like standard process
tomography the second look just like
process tomography except we took the
process out
we're just essentially doing tomography
on the on fiducials okay so you you run
you run these experiments you get
experimental frequencies that are
approximately equal to the underlying
probabilities for these different
experiments and then you run these
through some pretty straightforward
linear algebra and you get an estimate
of your data so you can you can write
down explicitly what your estimate of
the state preparation the measurement
effect and the gates off there is a cost
though to giving up on having a pre
calibrated frame of reference and sort
of the way to see that is if we imagine
that I take my gate set and I transform
it by some invertible map B so any
invertible map we call this a gauge
transformation i will now have a
different gate right it will be as just
an array of numbers it's just a
completely different array of numbers
what the problem is the predicted
probabilities the only experimental be
accessible things that we can see are
still the same so what this means is
when I have a gauge freedom when I have
this this particular gauge freedom it
means that I have an equivalence class
on gate set so given a gate that there's
actually a whole equivalence class that
are all physically equivalent to that
underlying gate set now this all of a
sudden times like this could be
problematic right because we said well
what do we want to do we want to be able
to compute things like diamond law and
diamond norm is very clearly not gauge
invariant right if I change the gauge of
the the gate set of the gate that I put
in as you to compute the diamond arm
that the diamond arm can vary wildly so
so what can we do about this and is this
really problematic so fortunately
there's a pretty straight
towards solution all we have to do is
optimize over the the gauge group to
minimize the distance between the target
gate set and the Gator that we've
reconstructed and you might think this
sounds at least vaguely like we're
cheating somehow but we're really not
because given that a gate set forms an
equivalent class overall physically
identical gate that I can just pick the
one from that front from the gain driver
essentially uh to to get the gates that
that gives me the best score okay ah so
we've done this I'm sorry the question
good question children some would be
willing to basically saying well but
ultimate of a choice was the station
measurement means rate over basic retain
like or for the state preparation means
rate so thank you
you know normally in experimental day
well I'm actually drink you a
measurement of all podiatry and like
your approach is saying well I'm
actually going to compute the room for
my purposes if I'm intransitive thin and
on to the quality laminate actually this
should be interpreted as a measurement a
local option or view / 0.1 hat sure sure
um that's that's a good example but it's
a little bit broader than that too right
because we can also be doing sort of non
orthogonal transformations as well right
but about it but absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely
ah so we sort of understand what it
means to computed all frames which is
more or less what he is doing to us I
said more or less it's sure right less
general than that but one could imagine
the following suppose you had a
transformations apply to different
points in the computation that could
make segments of the computation better
in that gauge and optimize that that is
let B be B sub I mm-hmm so so if you if
you did that um then then this wouldn't
this wouldn't in general Nessa this I
don't think this would preserve the the
underlying probabilities right the
physically observable probabilities at
the end because you need to be able to
stitch together right it has to be the
case that when I multiply G 1 by G 2 if
I then you know subject G 1 to some so
it's got be G 1 B inverse and I've got G
to the B G 1 B inverse those B's cancel
so if I change the B's those are going
to cancel anymore no sir you have to
change the cavitations well obviously
I'm not talking about constructively
changing computation based on your
tomography to decide which volume basis
to compute in and make it so assuming
the pause maybe your least error-prone
problem but I don't know hmm that's
interesting interesting thought an
optimization stretch or I have to think
about that that's an interesting thought
they may be some way to think about it
so right so so which we have in true
right Karara right right so we have this
gauge freedom but we can deal with it
we've gone and we've done this l GST
procedure on trapped ion system at
sandia it works uh but there are still
some issues so even though it gives us
full tomographic reconstruction modules
the gauge which we can take care of and
its self consistent the accuracy is
limited by one of the square root of the
number of measurements that you perform
as a standard quantum limit scaling and
if we want to get down to something like
10 to the minus 4 in diamond norm then
we're also looking at something like you
know order 10 to the eighth experiments
or extra mile repetitions so can we do
something better than this
could we for example you know reach the
Heisenberg limit it turns out that we
can't improve the accuracy scaling and
the way that we do this is we use long
sequences that consists of short
repeated sequences and so the illustrate
sort of how this works to start with a
little toy example imagine that you've
got a gate that is some very small Sigma
Z rotation
okay and your task is to determine that
this operation is different from the
identity well what you can do is you can
prepare your state perform the gate and
then do a measurement and if you do this
you need to repeat this process on the
order of 1 over theta squared times in
order to distinguish from the identity
alternatively you can push your gate L
times that you've brought your state
vector all the way around to the
opposite side of the Bloch sphere and
now with only one order one measurement
you can distinguish this from the
identity what have we done here we've
amplify coherent errors through
repetition so this is to say right we
can measure with accuracy plus minus
theta either repeating the gate order 1
times and then performing 1 over theta
squared measurements rep repetitions of
this experiment or we apply the gate or
1 over theta times then we need only
order 1 repetitions experiment to
distinguish it from the identity now of
course you might say wait a second that
seems that seems neat but I feel like
you're cheating again because how do you
know what L is supposed to be if you
don't know what theta is this is a very
reasonable objection and in point of
fact what we wind up having to do
because we don't know what theta is in
advance we proceed iteratively so you do
this experiment for l equals 1 for l
equals 2 for 8 and so on so you can sort
of bootstrap your way along making sure
that you don't take essentially the the
wrong root of the polynomial you don't
get an extraneous root and this way we
can you know figure out what the phase
is this is very similar to certain phase
estimation protocols so you might ask
then well if this works to amplify the
errors can we just make all of our
experiments consist of doing this where
for the different gate just take a gate
and repeat it more and more times and
then that just be the collection of
experiment that we want to perform so
this is a good start but it's not
complete of what we would have to do as
well is we need some other sequences to
can be sensitive to other kinds of
errors so for example if I have tilt
error that I want to amplify if I just
repeat the gate a bunch of times with
the till there eventually I will echo
out the tilt error that's present so we
need to somehow catalyze those errors
turn the till tears into phase errors so
when you do sequences like GX Gy for
example in X PI over 2 rotation on Y PI
over 2 rotation then repeat that period
4 times etc so the idea is that we want
to perform these kinds of experiments to
get what we call long sequence GST so we
wanted to want to be able to amplify all
the possible errors that we can witness
in a gate set and we repeat not just the
individual bear gates themselves but
collections of short sequences we call
each individual short sequence a germ
and the idea is we want to a complete
set of germs so that we can amplify all
of the errors in the gate set and I'm
not going to the details as to how you
select the germs it's a pretty
straightforward way to do it to make
sure that you are sensitive to all all
of the the error parameters in the gate
set and then what you do is you perform
experiments that look like this you
start with a state preparation you have
your input fiducial you take your germ
you repeat at some number of times and
then you have some measurement with some
measurements fiducial ok and you get
frequency estimates for these different
weighted inner products and then given
an estimate of the gate set what you can
do is you can compute a log likelihood
or a chi-squared school and what you
want to is you want to find the gate set
estimate that either maximizes the log
likelihood or minimizes the chi-square
okay and so you can do this use
numerical optimization techniques to
estimate the the gate set such that you
can minimize chi-squared or maximize log
l of course in the same way that you
can't just skip to the end with the the
toy example I showed by just repeating
the gate 1 over theta x to begin with
you need to proceed iteratively so you
start by
performing just l GST to get an initial
estimate of the gate set then you
perform your experiments where you
repeat your germs once you come up with
an estimate for your gate set based on
that data you then go to the next
generation where you repeat the gates
the germs twice then four times in cell
wanted to be come up with a final GST
estimate and so why do we do this
iteratively this is essentially we're
going to avoid the wrong branch of the
solution and this one free technical
point for numerical stability reasons we
wind up minimizing the chi-squared value
for all of the initial overall but the
last generation of data on the last
generation we maximize the log likely on
so how does this actually wind up
performing so we'll look at some
simulated long sequence GST analysis on
theirs we simulated data on an identity
X pi over 2 y pi over 2 gate set with
some small unitary error and force B
what's the error of the estimate has its
scale so if we look at the diamond norm
in measuring the error of the estimate
it goes as 1 over the maximum sequence
length that is to say we're Heisenberg
limit as R the error bars for this
protocol this is of course all well and
good on a laptop how does it actually
perform in the lab well there are a
couple things that we might want to be a
little wary of for one thing we can't
compare to the true gates right so I
can't actually hope to get a plot like
this insofar as I can't compare my
estimate to what the actual underlying
gate is also what happens at the errors
are non Markovian because I simulated
the data I know that the errors that I
put in are Markovian right so
fortunately there are or we don't have
to worry too much because we can still
compute reliable error bars so the error
bars are really big than we know that we
don't need to we ought entrust the
estimate that much and we can also
quantify the non-markovian any basically
by seeing how well our estimate fits the
data that generated that estimate so to
look sort of pictorially
how we might represent scoring the
non-markovian 'ti which is a nice little
graphical representation where we have
on the x-axis we're going to plot length
of the gate string and on the y-axis
we're going to have the different drums
and what we're going to do is we're
going to put each individual sequence
each individual gate string or a farm
circuit we're going to assign a little
box - alright info so each of these
boxes we can break down into a another
six by six grid of boxes correspond to
the six input fiducial states and the
six measurement fiducials that we
perform and if we fit that that gate
sequence that that experiment gate
sequence data well with our estimate
we'll color it blue and if we don't fit
it well we'll color it red so let's look
at some simulated data we get lots and
lots of blue a little bit of red right
why why do we get red well we expect
that these scores here we expect the
chi-square or the log likelihood scores
to be chi-squared distributed and so if
the null hypothesis is true then we
should see some small number of bad
scores and otherwise see see good scores
if the null hypothesis is not true you
have an experimental data set here we
get a lot of red so we can fit the data
all right particularly at low sequence
length small sequences but as the
sequences get longer we do a worse and
worse job of fitting the data even
though we're looking at the best fit to
the data given the model the model isn't
very good okay so one of the things that
we wanted an October protocol want to be
calibration free we want to be complete
we want to be efficient and we want to
be able to certify or question that oh
well I didn't tease be significantly
worse and apply and actually I could
gave as an excellent question and it
turns out that it depends on the details
of the identity operation that you're
doing and we're going to come back to
this point in a few slides so they're
very very good very
good observation so what do we actually
do with this tomographic protocol that
satisfies the various criteria that we
wanted well we're going to try to use it
to fix experimental qubits and so this
is what we did that's India so over the
course of about a year we use GST to
characterize and improve a single
trapped 171 ytterbium plus ion qubit and
as you'll see in a moment the first
iteration was extremely noisy very non
Markovian and by the end of the year we
were able to certify that the cubic
behavior was very close from Markovian
on sequins without about two line 8,192
and it producer gates that that we were
able to certify to be below the
threshold for fault tolerance so here is
the abbreviated story so we start off
with a data set that we try to fit with
GST and we get loss and lots and lots of
red so sure we've aggregated the 6x6
grid into just into single blocks and
you'll see it's lots and lots of red and
so this tells us that there's lots of
drift going on there you know somehow
somehow we don't have a very stable
qubit so the first thing that we did to
fix this was we introduced
dv1 pulses dynamically correcting gate
sequences to make the gate more stable
took more data and we get luck bluer
scores still not perfect still still
have a lot of red so a lot of model
violation so what we then did is we
introduced some more drift control on
the electronics and we also realized
that we weren't using a full set of
germs so we we expanded our our germ set
to be complete on all the big 8 set
parameters and ran GST again well it
still doesn't look great right we still
still have a lot of red but there's
something interesting if we if we look
closely here
we notice that the worst sequences are
the ones that include the identity
something is funny about the identity
well for the identity what we were doing
is we were just idling the system just
doing nothing for one one gate time and
I said well maybe maybe we should try
something a little bit different
let's do dynamical be coupling on the
identity and all of a sudden it looks
much more blue it's much nicer we still
go have a couple of squares that aren't
perfect and those both include the
identity so it's let's do go to a
higher-order dynamical decoupling
sequence for the identity and see what
we get so we do the further GI
compensation and we now go to a maximum
L of 8,192 this is a total 4650 sequence
57 sequences with 50 clicks or
repetitions per sequence for a total of
two hundred thirty-two thousand eight
hundred and fifty experimental
repetitions and so here's now the full
data set for the final run and it looks
like this so now we've gone and
disaggregated the the boxes and we can
see it looks very nice and very
Markovian so we certified here the gates
look pretty Markovian of course what are
the gates actually look like I said
nothing about what the gates are
actually doing so let's take a look at
that here are the estimates of the
process matrices and if you take a look
you don't need to look too closely
except I want to point out that any
number that is close to one should be
one any number that's close to minus one
should be minus one and any number
that's close to 0 should be zero and
you'll see that we are indeed pretty
close on all counts and here are the
error bars on a per element basis we
have error bars of about 10 to the minus
5 so it looks like they're really close
of course this doesn't actually tell you
what the fidelity is the diamond norms
are adult so why don't we go compute
what the
so we can do that and we see that the
diamond norm on each gate is below 10 to
the minus 4 so we have certified that
our gate that is below the diamond or
threshold poor fault tolerance we
published this just a just a few months
ago in nature communication so what's
the moral of the story we were able to
use GST to diagnose and correct
stochastic error unitary er and non
Markovian error you can see how these
metrics evolve over time so what we want
to do next well there are a bunch of
other qcv protocols that we've developed
implemented and tested at Sandia I'm
going to talk just briefly about a few
of them and one of the things that we've
worked on is is to cuba GST so here are
some results experimental results from
some some collaborators of ours and now
here are the color box plots for their
experiment I've turned the box plot that
we looked at earlier I turn it on its
side so we've got a lot of germs and we
got 17 germs okay and we go out to here
this only goes out to a maximum length
of C one two four eight sixteen and so
we don't go to too far and you'll notice
there are lots and lots of experiments
that you need to take so to Cuba GST is
working but there are plenty of things
we want to do to improve it we want to
be able to reduce the number of
sequences here because this is this is a
lot for an experimental group to go and
have to gather it still takes a while to
compute when when this was computed it
took several hours to to compute these
estimates now we've got it down to order
tens of minutes on a laptop we'd still
like to make it even faster especially
if you want to be able to do something
for you know in real time to be fixing
your gates we want to be able to improve
the memory usage you might be asking
were they
our bars on these estimates well we
don't have them yet because of memory
constraints and trying to you know work
work around those those sorts of issues
but the bottom line is this is looking
very promising um there are some
additional two cubed GST improvements
that we've made since this data was
taken which I've not mentioned here but
we think that photon certification
should ultimately be feasible for two
qubit gates as well another thing that
we've worked on is robust phase
estimation this is a protocol that was
developed by Shelby Kimmel Ted Yoder and
Wong hollow at at MIT a few years ago
and then working with Shelby we went and
implemented we came up with a software
implementation of robust phase
estimation and then went and ran it on
an experimental system at Sandia and the
idea is this is for diagnosing and
correcting coherent errors recurred
pretty rotation errors are phase errors
on your gate you can think of the data
that you take as being Robbie or Ramsey
sequences or plus plus the ideas it's
logarithmically space and it's pretty
straightforward analysis of that data to
then come up with estimates of the phase
angles and we found that we can estimate
rotation angles within four times ten to
the minus four radians with only one
hundred and seventy six total
experimental repetitions so this is this
is very nice as well and this was just
published last month in PRL we've
developed some tools for context
dependence detection uh you might want
to know is my gate set at noon the same
as it is three hours later
without having to run GST or is it the
same if I have a light switch on in the
other lab or whatever you want to know
are the gate sets taken what with the
gate sets under certain different
experimental circumstances are they the
same gate set without having to actually
go ahead and do a full gate to
tomography analysis and conveniently
this is very similar to comparing coin
biases what I'm
by that is each individual experiment
that you perform each individual gate
sequence has some underlying probability
for a Bernoulli random variable right
and basically like doing a coin toss and
so what we want to do is once they given
a particular gate sequence in this
context and in this other context is the
underlying random variable that does it
have the same weight where the same bias
and can we can we figure that out with
some sort of statistical significance
well in the is there any statistical
significance we can assign to our
assessment and there is it's very
straightforward to do you just compute
log likelihoods for the data under the
hypothesis that you have the same
underlying parameter and under the
hypothesis that you don't and you can
compare them and come up with a score
for that it's just a few dozen lines of
code to to perform this test you can run
this on any data set GST data set and
our B data set you name it okay and to
give you a picture sort of a sense of
what the results look like given the
various log likelihood scores you can go
ahead and turn those into p-values so we
can look at a histogram of p-values for
simulated data where I just take a gate
set I simulate some data I take that
same gate set I simulate some more data
I've got two data sets generated by the
same underlying physical gate set and
compute the p-value for the different
sequences that we see this blue line is
what we expect to see and indeed we see
that everything matches up nicely I can
instead put some very small random
rotations on the gate set and then run
the experiment again if I do that you
can see the p-values we see significant
model violations very easy to detect
okay I'm very sensitive to to these
relatively small changes we've gone
ahead and tested this experimentally on
a curette system at Sandia
and so now again simulation with with no
drift with no change it's again more or
less what we expect to see and then you
look at what we have in the lab and even
though we don't see nearly as much model
violation as we saw in the previous
slide we still see some so we can tell
there has been some change between the
two different data sets that were taken
several hours apart so the last thing
that I'd like to talk about for just a
minute is pigsty this is Python gates a
tomography implementation this is our
software suite that we've developed at
Sandia we've taken a - tomography we've
put it in here we've also now taken
additional qcv protocols like randomized
benchmarking as well as these other
tests that I just talked about
it's extensively documented you can go
and generate very thorough reports on
from GST data about your qubit can also
give you more digestible smaller reports
if you want and any experimentalist if
there should happen to be any here
they're welcome to you of it theorists
are welcome to play with this - it's
very easy to use it to generate
simulated Markovian data if you have
your own way method of generating
simulated data you're welcome to try it
on that as well
we would love to hear from you if you
have any interesting observations about
behavior in the system in with with the
software you know can you find flaws
with what we're doing you know find a
physical model that we can't properly
diagnose we would love to hear about
that so please if you're interested
email picks is India gov or me and so
just to conclude then we are developing
and releasing and using qcv protocols
right now to make ever better qubits
there's a lot of challenges that we want
to to tackle we want to be able to deal
with systems that have more than two
qubits right once we've got two qubits
that's nice but we know that for
universal farm computation we need a lot
more than to Cuba so we're thinking
about you know what what are ways in
which we can analyze larger systems
especially because we know that we can't
hope to
we write down all the parameters for a
gate set as soon as we get up to order
just you know a handful of cubits right
we certainly can't make sense of what
those parameters are either in any sort
of digestible reasonable fashion so one
thing we've been thinking about instead
of having full descriptions of the error
processes we instead try to verify error
models and say okay you the
experimentalist tell us what do you
think the kinds of errors are that your
system can experience what's a
parametrized error model with a
relatively small number of parameters
that you think could be messing up your
system and then we can run GST or
something like GST on the system try to
fit the data to that model and see if we
do a good job of fitting the model do
good outfitting the law we can say hey
guess what you've done a very good job
of guessing at what kind of error
processes you're experiencing um and if
not back to the drawing board and say
okay well what are what are other things
that could be going on and of course
there's still this issue of
understanding what do all these numbers
mean and as we go to more more cubits
we're going to get more and more numbers
we are always looking for new
collaborators to work with also always
looking for new platforms new
architectures to test our models to test
our glasses on and so with that I would
like to thank Robin Bloom code Erik
Nielsen John gamble Peter Mount Johnson
is rahi and Dan lobster from Sandia
National Laboratories and Nathan we are
Microsoft and also thanks to all of you
for coming and listening thank you we
have any credit questions a lot of
personal security I'll just for you to
tell you the results for lumpiness DC or
is at Penn State starting from scratch
for October in Ocean
so you can do sort of disaggregated 2
cubic GS
so basically two qubit GST now looks
like one qubit GST on this qubit one
qubit you see on this qubit and then an
additional set of experiment that
together allow you to do to keep of GS
but it's but but the way that the
optimization works you know you're still
looking at all the data in total but
what you can do is you can take the two
cubed GST output and sort of want us to
do a partial trace in some sense to say
okay this is this is what one qubit
looks like this is what one qubit looks
like any further questions
at Becky's FL I'm sure so a while ago I
asked you a question about about the
robust maintenance major particular the
lower bound that's knowing for the label
variant for a defamation which is high
over 2 now which was thrown above the
line that you showed that if you remind
me what the explanation but is apparent
violation and lower balance I'll put you
to your side right right so so um we are
still puzzled by this one so the so so
one of the things so sorry sync up I
think one thing to keep in mind right is
that we know that as we increase the
number of repetitions of the experiment
that we perform we can get increased
accuracy right we're going to just keep
shifting this line down until we wind up
getting a sufficiently low error rate
that we wind up getting onto the wrong
branch and then it flat one right so I
don't think this would be answers your
question directly uh but I think I so so
um so the whole level bound how does
that take into account the total the
total data acquisition rate does that
because there's the optimal processing
of any data that you can end up getting
assuming you know from prior 4 p.m. then
it provides a bound on the best
posterior variance that you can have in
your estimate
okay so right so I guess I would think
we're not with the exception of the
first generation of data we're not
assuming uniform part oh right nNG that
he plays all right ok very good
and deal alright well then don't think
anyone left
[Applause]